foreign
if we're going to just talk in magnitude
VO2 max and muscular strength stand in A
League of Their Own
so there's really nothing that's within
the zip code of those two metrics so
having very very high VO2 max for your
age and sex and being very strong
I mean again they have more of a
positive impact than any single thing we
can think of has a negative impact and
that includes
having end-stage renal disease like
being on the wait list for a kidney
while you get dialysis being a smoker
having high blood pressure having type 2
diabetes being obese the downside of
those things is relatively small
compared to the upside of having a high
VO2 max and being very strong
so we almost shouldn't even talk about
things until people are willing to
accept that fact and take the steps
necessary to address them
now you might say well okay how many
people can become very very strong or
have a very high VO2 max and the answer
is I don't know like I don't know
especially on the VO2 max side you know
to get into that top 2.5 percent of the
population where you really start to see
an enormous gap between you and
everybody else in terms of lifespan
yeah maybe maybe only
a quarter of the population has the
potential to get there
but the point is everybody has the
potential to be more fit than they are
you know outside of people who are
already doing everything they can and so
just going from being in the bottom 25
of the population to the 25th to 50th
percentile of the population
Cuts your risk of all-cause mortality in
half at any point in time
there's nothing that compares to that
like there's no drug out there that's
going to do that so
again I think we could talk about drugs
all day long and how I think they're
really important and how we can think
about controlling APO B and you know
rapamycin and metform and all those
other things
all that stuff is you know it's it's
pixie dust compared to what these things
are
on the strength side the same thing
anyone who's got older parents knows
this
if you really want to watch somebody
suffer when they're aging
you watch them losing their cognition
and you watch them losing their physical
body you watch them lose the ability to
move around with ease to to have balance
to be pain-free all of these things well
a big part of that is being strong
you know strength is
something we can actually hang on to as
we age you know we lose quickness long
before we lose strength
and
you know that's that's the good news the
bad news is it you have to be very
deliberate in how you train it right so
I'm sure on the podcast you've discussed
type 1 and type 2 muscle fibers so
people are probably familiar with that
why don't you reiterate that so we
basically have you know our muscles are
made up of these fibers they're very
unique properties so muscles are these
multicellular things where the the cells
are these long sort of fibers that
contract past each other and that's what
creates the contraction of a muscle
but if you dig a little bit deeper you
have different types of fibers so you
have type 1 fibers which are fueled
mostly if not entirely by an aerobic
process
so they can use fat they can use glucose
but they do so in the presence of oxygen
primarily they're very slow to fatigue
which is mostly where the name comes
from
but they don't generate that much force
so these are the muscle fibers that are
mostly on display when you're you know
walking or just carrying out activities
of daily living right commonly called
slow twitch as you alluded to slow
twitch yeah so you can do things for a
long period of time and these things
don't fatigue
conversely another subset of these
fibers are type 2 fibers and they're
called fast twitch muscle fibers and
they're fast to fatigue now they're much
more powerful so when a type 2 fiber
contracts far more is happening it's
generating far more Force
but it's doing so with a different
metabolic strategy so it's glycolytic
it's just using glucose or you know
broken down glycogen
and it's going to fatigue quickly so
it's accumulating metabolic byproducts
that are leading to fatigue so there's a
reason why if I say Tim jump up and down
as high as you can as many times as you
can this is not going to be a long
exercise right we don't have to sit and
wait two hours for you to finish that
you're going to fatigue pretty quickly
if you're doing maximal jumps whereas if
I say jump rope you could do that for 30
minutes easily and if you're you know
relatively fit person
so you get the sense of the difference
now as we age we lose power and
explosiveness
more than anything else and we lose that
the soonest and that's due to the type 2
fiber the atrophy of the type 2 fiber
and this again this comes back down to
strategy so that's why
if you want to live a longer better life
you have to have a strategy in place for
maintaining type 2 fibers
and you're not going to get that without
resistance
you won't you know you can't say look I
I play tennis every day I walk every day
those things are great they're not doing
something for your type 2 fibers